[Musique]
c'est tellement difficile que ça fait
mal au cœur
quand tu sais pas
pour moi il y a pas de fermeture
38 officiellement 38 c'est le nombre
d'enfants qui ne sont jamais rentrés à
la maison après leur passage dans des
pensionnats pour autochtones au Québec
c'est le chiffre qu'a retenu la
commission Vérité réconciliation mais
est-ce que des enfants disparus des
communautés autochtones du Québec sont
passés inaperçus
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard ils nous ont
annoncé qu'elle était morte
mais ils ont dit
ne parlez pas de ça elle est partie non
parlait plus donc
avec des survivants et des historiens on
a enquêté et on a découvert d'autres cas
nous sommes ce que nous avons choisi à
se souvenir mais nous sommes aussi ce
que nous avons choisi à oublier
ici Mariemont Denis bienvenue à enquête
jenny patchiano a passé 8 ans dans un
pensionnat pour autochtone sur l'île de
forge au bord de la baie James mais il a
fallu 70 ans et la découverte de
possibles sépulture anonyme à camelots
pour qu'elle s'ouvre enfin sur son
expérience
quand j'ai entendu parler de la
découverte en Colombie-Britannique
et l'horreur a refait surface j'avais
déjà vu des enfants se faire frapper
gifler
je comprenais pas la mort à cette époque
avec les 215 on recevait des appels les
gens disaient je me souviens ça ouvert
les yeux à beaucoup de gens
[Musique]
fort de ces nouveaux témoignages les
cris de la Baie James ont décidé
d'entreprendre des fouilles autour de
deux anciens pensionnats la tâche
s'annonce ardue et cette quête ne
révèlera qu'une partie de la vérité sur
les enfants décédés dans les pensionnats
du Québec le nombre d'enfants qui ne
sont pas revenus officiellement au
Québec ces 38
mais il y en a d'autres qu'on a déplacé
transféré déportés
et dont nous avons trouvé la trace
[Musique]
cela signifie grande rivière
c'est le lieu habité le plus au nord
accessible par la route
à quelques kilomètres de là le
traversier mène à l'île de forge où ont
été construits les deux premiers
pensionnats pour autochtone au Québec
dans les années 30
jenny patchiano a fréquenté le
pensionnat anglicant de sainte Philips
sur un près d'une décennie comme sa mère
avant elle qui a fait partie de la
première cohorte de pensionnaires
[Musique]
elle était très en colère parce qu'elle
avait 12 ans qu'elle avait l'habitude de
se promener sur les terres
personne n'avait jamais vu au vécu dans
un pensionnat et vous les pas y aller
mais elle n'avait pas le choix
la fréquentation des pensionnats était
obligatoire pour les enfants autochtone
elle m'a raconté qu'une fois quand elle
travaillait dans la cuisine
la nourriture qu'on leur a demandé de
cuisiner était pleine de verres
on leur a dit de ne pas les enlever de
les mettre dans le chaudron c'est ce
qu'ils ont dû manger
toute petite encore
ignorante de l'expérience de sa mère
Jenny rêvait d'aller à l'école
une de mes cousines est revenue de sa
première année avec une robe à carreaux
et des chaussures noires brillantes et
je vous les ressembler à ça aussi
elle avait surtout une grande soif
d'apprendre mais elle découvre à son
tour la violence du pensionnat
on nous rappelait constamment que nous
étions des sauvages
l'ignorance sauvage païen et si on
s'améliorait pas il y avait aucun espoir
pour nous
on a fini par le croire
et le pire a resurgi dans ses souvenirs
à 10 ans une enfant est presque morte
sous ses yeux
la première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé
c'est l'histoire de cette fille
et même maintenant quand j'y pense je me
rends compte que
je m'en suis toujours pas remis
[Musique]
l'histoire de cet enfant Jenny va mettre
du temps à nous la raconter son
témoignage et d'autres ont finalement
convaincu les cris de chez sa Siby
d'entreprendre des fouilles
il y avait des histoires qui ont partagé
ça c'est pour quoi il voulait que qu'on
vérifie certaines endroits sur l'île
mais par où commencer on ne dispose que
de fragments d'archives il révèle les
problèmes récurrents de financement et
des listes d'enfants malades beaucoup de
malades certains admis aux pensionnats
avec la tuberculose les archives sont
mieux être en revanche sur où seraient
enterrés les enfants
la première école a ouvert les portes en
1930 on est 2022
c'est presque 100 ans
puis il y a pas beaucoup de
survivants qui peuvent nous dire
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 1930 40 50
et pas beaucoup
fait partie d'un groupe d'expansionaires
qui a recueilli les récits des années
lui-même avait 6 ans à son entrée au
pensionnat en cliquant
on s'ennuyait tu finis par te sentir
abandonné pourquoi ils ont mis ici parce
que c'est parce que j'attendais
c'était assez dur là-dedans il fallait
se protéger
[Musique]
les pensionnaires pour les convertir et
surtout bénéficier des subsides du
gouvernement on va chercher les enfants
aussi loin qu'un Mouchet à 1000 km de là
bien des témoignages inquiétants
concernent le pensionnat catholique plus
éloigné du village
il y avait un sous-sol
et le plancher n'était pas en béton
c'était juste la terre battue
le bâtiment n'existe plus mais des
histoires récurrentes ont fait surface
sur les secrets qui leur est russe les
dans son sous-sol
[Musique]
une des choses qu'on m'a raconté
quelqu'un a vu des croix et des gens qui
apportaient des fleurs en bas
[Musique]
vous ne comprenez pas tout c'est plus
tard pour réaliser oh c'est peut-être ce
qui est arrivé
de l'établissement catholique il ne
reste aujourd'hui qu'un cimetière
possiblement celui de l'infirmerie deux
rangées de croix une vingtaine de noms
dont on sait plus de choses mais il y
aurait d'autres lieux d'inhumation selon
un des anciens
il a dit il y a eu une épidémie et vous
devriez vérifier
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y a une tombe
quelque part comme une fausse commune
16 décès confirmés à ce jour à forge 6
chez les catholiques 10 chez les
anglicans
les témoignages mèneront peut-être à
d'autres découvertes ils ont permis
d'identifier cinq endroits ou
entreprendre des fouilles sur l'île
si on ne se fie que aux écrits et de
plus en plus on aura accès qu'à des
écrits on va avoir des soucis donc il y
a vraiment les témoignages des anciens
pensionnaires qui sont primordiaux parce
que c'est ça qui va nous permettre de
mieux mettre en perspective tout ce
qu'on va mettre du temps à analyser le
temps presse le temps presse oui et il y
a aussi beaucoup d'enfants qu'on
entendra jamais
en plus des foyers fédéraux destinés aux
Inuits et des deux écoles de forge
quatre autres pensionnats veulent le
jour au Québec à compter des années 50
maliottenham Saint-Marc de figueries
[Musique]
on vient pourtant de recommander
l'abolition des pensionnats ailleurs au
pays mais au Québec les églises militent
pour construire ses établissements coûte
que coûte
il y avait encore dans les années 50
énormément de paternalisme dans l'idée
que ils allaient faire mieux que les
parents et de toute façon on voit quand
même dans les écrits dans les archives
qu'on peut trouver des différentes
congrégations que il y avait encore un
mépris très répandu dans la société en
général envers les autochtones
les pensionnaires n'échappent pas au
service physique sexuels et
psychologiques mais les morts seraient
plus rares
il n'y a pas beaucoup de plus de
ressources qui sont données par le
gouvernement fédéral aux pensionnat mais
la santé des enfants semblent meilleurs
notamment parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
campagne de vaccination et notamment
contre la tuberculose
mais les récentes découvertes de
cameloups ont semé le doute des
discussions vont bon train partout au
Québec sur la nécessité d'entreprendre
des fouilles pour connaître la vérité
[Musique]
mais une autre question s'impose et si
des enfants d'ici avaient été inhumés
ailleurs dans d'autres provinces
[Musique]
après la pause une survivante à la
recherche de la tombe de son frère
[Musique]
pendant longtemps il n'y avait pas de
pensionnat pour autochtone au Québec
mais on sait pas gêné pour envoyer les
enfants dans d'autres provinces en fait
ça s'est fait pendant plus d'un siècle
on a perdu la trace de beaucoup d'entre
eux
[Musique]
on estime à environ 13000 le nombre
d'enfants en octobre qui ont séjourné
dans des foyers et pensionnats au Québec
mais d'autres sont allés grossir les
rangs des pensionnats dans d'autres
provinces surtout en Ontario
[Musique]
se souvient du moment où il a été
arraché à sa famille à wasquehaganish
pour être envoyé dans le Nord de
l'Ontario
est arrivé avec des avions taxi
on remplit ses avions et amener les
enfants de la communauté vers les
différents pensionnats
c'est un programme scolaire pour ses
enfants
[Musique]
quand je suis entré j'étais à la
maternelle et je ne comprenais pas ce
qui arrivait
il était loin d'être le seul
[Musique]
nous étions presque tous décrits à
mousse Factory
les enfants
[Musique]
décrits sont envoyés à mousse factrice
chinois et aussi loin que Brandford des
enfants à nichnabe et Abenaki sont aussi
disséminés en Ontario des Micmacs et des
malaises sites en nouvelle-école mais la
toute première vague d'enfants déportée
venait de la région de Montréal
des USA 26 les premiers enfants qui ont
été envoyés dans les pensionnats
résidentiels de l'Ontario c'est les mois
eric pouliotisdale est un chercheur
il a épluché d'obscures documents de
recensement et découvert que trois
autres vagues d'enfants de Kanawake
Cannes s'attaquer et à quoi ça ce n'est
ont suivi pendant plus d'un siècle dans
des établissements où la vie était
parfois très dure
[Musique]
l'État ne fournit pas donc les étudiants
sont obligés de devenir en quelque sorte
des esclaves
industriels agricoles de la ferme pour
s'occuper de leur auto Suzanne donc ils
vont finalement en classe une journée
par semaine
à l'époque le taux de mortalité y est
cinq fois plus élevé que dans la
population générale
seulement qu'à chinois le registre des
décès contient les noms au moins 7
enfants du Québec des mois pour la
plupart
[Musique]
et le travail d'identification n'est pas
terminé
et ce qui est possible que des enfants
comptabilisés dans d'autres provinces
mais qui en fait était des enfants qui
étaient originaires du Québec et que le
chef de 38 peut-être ne reflète pas ça
c'est très facile
et l'archiviste en chef du centre
national pour la vérité et la
réconciliation il a la tâche difficile
de compléter les archives de la
commission qui a pris fin en 2015 celle
provenant du Québec peut nombreuses ont
posé un défi particulier
il est événement cherche qui était à
bilingue qui a une connaissance de des
archives et aussi une connaissance des
communautés autochtone
nous avons réussi à obtenir l'unique
rapport qui porte sur le Québec réalisé
en 2012 pour le compte de la Commission
il ne présente qu'une partie de la
réalité québécoise des pensionnats et
n'avait jamais été rendu public
je sais qu'il faut travailler beaucoup
plus au Québec et de le CVR fait pas
assez de temps au Québec il faut faire
là comme je dis vers
ce rapport démontre qu'on pourrait tirer
beaucoup plus des archives par exemple
ce récit d'un jeune a bien acquis du
Québec en route vers les pensionnats de
Chapelot et de chinois il y avait 16
survivants dit-il nous étions 37 mais
certains sont morts
cela remet en question le bilan du
Québec nous sommes en train de faire les
recherches pour trouver un beaucoup plus
des enfants et cette norme va seulement
augmenter
oui ça c'est un plan de feuilles et ma
saganache et ses frères et soeurs ont
passé des années dans des pensionnats en
Ontario et l'un d'eux
moi j'essaie de mettre
c'est
dans les magasins à ma mère
quoi
la télévision de CBC en langue crie elle
et 10 de ses frères et soeurs ont été
forcés de quitter le village de was
wanipi au Québec pour être dispersé dans
plusieurs établissements différents en
Ontario dans les années 50 et 60
[Musique]
se trouve le mouraque Institute le plus
ancien pensionnat au pays
le 27 petites chambres en dessous des
escaliers là
j'ai qu'un punition une fois ils m'ont
enfermé dans une coupe d'âge c'est pas
combien de temps
dans le noir
une centaine d'enfants ils sont morts
des fouilles sont déjà en cours on
soupçonne la présence de tombes anonymes
la famille saganache a longtemps cherché
la tombe de John son aîné voici l'unique
photo de lui à 6 ans il a été arraché à
ses parents et placés à bord d'un avion
pour une destination inconnue
puis lui enchanté par la fenêtre qui
était assis à la fin
c'est ce que ma mère me dit
John est arrivé à mousse factrice en
1954 il est mort quelques mois plus tard
sa famille n'a jamais su comment ni où
ça dépouille a été enterré
j'étais un tournage en 1994
[Musique]
j'étais
chez eux puis la réalisateur qui est
avec moi dans il y a décidé
que il était malade qu'il était à
l'hôpital puis qui est le rhumatisme
ce que tu manques qui mal de toi je ne
sais pas
j'ai dit j'aimerais aller voir où il est
enterré parce que moi je sais pas ma
famille le sait pas que je me sens aller
voir
son mari cherchait cherchait le nom de
deux grammaire puis dans le milieu
supposément que c'était mon frère qui
était enterré
la classe avait 20 minutes qui se
promène d'abord à l'autre puis la femme
c'est pas le nom
[Musique]
je fais ça sur une carte en bas j'ai
fait ça
[Musique]
ton frère est en dessous de toi
quel au moins je suis ce qui est
[Musique]
décédé le système simple la journée j'ai
trouvé sans ou ce qui était enterré
c'était 140
[Musique]
et ma pensée que l'histoire s'arrêtait
là
mais depuis les découvertes de camelots
un ancien pensionnaire c'est manifesté
il a raconté une version différente des
événements
il y a eu comme genre
ils l'ont trouvé en bas
[Musique]
qui était tellement tellement plus jeune
que d'autres qui étaient là puis me dire
que là même matin quand
on s'habiller
John fait maintenant partie de la liste
des victimes pas au Québec mais en
Ontario
on ignore combien d'enfants ayant été
déportés au total et combien ne sont pas
revenus
c'est tellement difficile que ça fait
mal au cœur
quand tu sais pas
pour moi il y a pas de fermeture encore
[Musique]
au retour et si les sépultures anonymes
ne se trouvaient pas là où on pense les
trouver
il est probable qu'il
n'est pas été enterré à côté des
pensionnats mais plutôt à côté de
l'Institut de santé en question
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'au Québec les pensionnats
sont arrivés beaucoup plus tard que dans
l'ouest du pays et que moins d'enfants
autochtones ils sont décédés mais avec
de nouveaux témoignages on se rend
compte qu'on a peut-être un portrait
partiel de ce chapitre extrêmement
sombre de l'histoire du Québec
le pensionnat de pointe bleu a m’acheté
williards et parmi les derniers à voir
le jour dans les années 60
ce sont là toutes des belles œuvres que
le bon Dieu notre père a fait pour
chacun de nous
[Musique]
de rares archives des pensionnats
québécois nous laissent entrevoir le
quotidien des enfants mais on sait
maintenant que derrière l'image se cache
de sonbre secret
pas étonnant donc que la découverte de
tombes anonyme ailleurs au pays est
amener les communautés à envisager des
recherches au
québecs officiellement on ne compte
aucune décès mais nous avons repéré le
cas d'au moins un pensionnaire transféré
à l'hôpital de Roberval où il est mort
[Musique]
il y aurait d'autres cas semblables
ce qu'on suppose c'est qu'il y avait des
enfants malades ils étaient ils
quittaient le pensionnat et ils étaient
envoyés dans des systèmes hospitaliers
donc si ils y sont des CD ce qu'on ne
sait pas il est probable qu'il
n'est pas été enterré à côté des
pensionnats mais plutôt à côté de
l'Institut de santé en question
on risque de faire de pénible découverte
autour d'un sien sanatorium le Centre
national pour la vérité et la
réconciliation nous confirme qu'un
ancien établissement autour de Montréal
intéresse de près des chercheurs en ce
moment il y a beaucoup de fausses comme
une près de cette hôpital et elle
travaille avec les soeurs maintenant
pour déterminer combien des enfants qui
qui sont là-bas mais il y en a beaucoup
je pense que à peu près cinq ans au
moins
[Musique]
mais parce que les pensionnats sont
arrivés plus tard les fosses communes
comme les tombes anonymes seraient plus
rares au Québec à ma lyoténam ou en
recensait un décès les consultations ont
permis d'en découvrir un de plus
mais on ne croit pas utile de faire des
fouilles
là-dessus aussi compte un décès mais les
travaux inédits de la Commission Vérité
et Réconciliation en révèle un deuxième
en 1969 à la suite d'une épidémie de
méningite qui a forcé la mise en
quarantaine du pensionnat aucune
décision n'a été prise encore au sujet
de fouiller éventuels
[Musique]
le cas de Saint-Marc de figri soulève
des questions aucun enfant n'y serait
mort selon les registres
cette photo inédite semble prouver le
contraire le directeur du pensionnat y
apparaît aux côtés
et les amis schlabais nous confirment
que trois enfants au total manqueraient
à la pelle
des fouilles sont probables
forge ou les fouilles devraient débuter
l'été prochain sera le premier endroit
où on verra si les soupçons se
confirment
le travail prendra deux à trois ans et
s'annonce complexe en raison du terrain
inégal et de la végétation qui a repris
ses droits
[Musique]
a été ramené au Québec cette fois à
forge il se souvient d'un enfant tombé
malade au pensionnat en cliquant des
cinq Philips dans les années 60
peut-être d'après mes souvenirs
il est mort ici dans le pensionnat parce
qu'il avait très froid des frissons et
tout
[Musique]
son nom n'apparaît pas au décompte
officiels au travers de témoignages en
fouillant des articles des archives et
des ouvrages historiques nous avons
identifié quatre décès non comptabilisés
à sainte-philippe
et 8 autres au pensionnat catholique
[Musique]
la maladie emportait bien des enfants
selon une religieuse et historienne des
sœurs grises
[Musique]
elle indique qu'il y avait à peu près
deux ou trois enfants qui mouraient par
année donc si on fait le décompte du
nombre d'années qui a duré le pensionnat
de Ford Georges on arrive assez vite à
des chiffres qui dépassent la trentaine
est parmi les derniers survivants qui
peuvent encore témoigner le souvenir
qu'il a honte et celui de la petite
Hélène bobbych
ose
chaque repas on devait sortir dehors
immédiatement
je vous souhaite elle est assise par
terre quand je suis entré dans la salle
de jeux
elle avait les jambes relevé comme ça
avec la tête sur ses genoux
la surveillante est arrivée
s'est mise à crier
debout avec toi d'or
elle a répondu je peux pas
je t'ai dit de te lever
je peux pas je suis malade et elle s'est
mise à lui donner des coups de pied sur
le côté ça
et la frappé dans le dos
la fille était allongée là en position
fœtale
c'était en février
il fait froid ici en février
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard ils nous ont
annoncé qu'elle était morte
[Musique]
ne parlez pas de ça elle est partie n'en
parlait plus donc
[Musique]
chaque nouveau cas comme ceux que nous
avons possiblement trouvé exigera des
recherches scrupuleuses pour obtenir
confirmation mais bien des indices
pointe désormais vers un bilan revu et
corrigé des victimes des pensionnats au
Québec
si les faux humaines à des découvertes
la suite représentera un grand défi
cela fait partie de nos croyances il ne
faut pas déranger les sépultures
on les perturbe surtout si vous creusez
près d'où les gens sont enterrés
je pense que ça rend les choses
difficiles
voudra-t-on exhumer des corps sera-t-il
jamais possible de les identifier
ce sera le prochain chapitre d'une
histoire dont personne ne connaît la fin
[Musique]
aux quatre coins de la province les
expansionnaires qu'ils soient issus des
Premières nations ou Inuits sont au cœur
d'une démarche qui fait appel à leur
résilience
on finit par survivre à 100 grandissant
tu veux pas t'en souvenir tu veux garder
ça secret tu l'enfouis quelque part pour
oublier mais ça s'oublie pas
ces souvenirs impossibles à effacer
appartiennent désormais à notre histoire
collective
[Musique]
nous sommes ce que nous avons choisi à
se souvenir mais nous sommes aussi ce
que nous devons choisir à oublier et
maintenant je pense que c'est la tombe
de faire reconnaissance et se souvenir
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les
pensionnats
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié
l'émission de ce soir la dernière de
l'année au nom de toute l'équipe je vous
souhaite un très joyeux temps des fêtes
et je vous donne rendez-vous en 2023
pour plein d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]